it is time for hatred mail hatred mail
of course a favorite moment of the week
for many in the audience although a
stressful moment for some I do get
emails from people saying that they are
sickened by the ignorance of hatred mail
what is hatred mail quick reminder so
what if the president's been accused of
sexual harassment 15 times or that he
paid hush money to a porn star at least
he never wore a tan suit patriot mail
written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom this week's hatred mail has you
know yesterday I interviewed PE
Moskowitz about how often frequently how
frequently people are misunderstanding
the concept of free speech that is a big
part of this week's hatred mail let's
take a listen David Parkman does like to
lie hey Mon you David Park man for
deleting my comments so you don't allow
free speech why did you delete the
biggest cults of personal eats are
around you not Trump David Park man show
you are in ace no my president Donald
Trump 2020 we see you in the arena
America is first is Donald Trump 2020
yeah I mean listen first of all there's
like a practical question here which is
I get emails all the time from people
saying David you're censoring me why are
you deleting my comments I can assure
you I am very very busy hosting and
researching the David Pakman show
running the business side of the David
Pakman show
and working on the ad agency side of the
David Pakman show and and our
organization I can't sit around and look
at and delete individual YouTube
comments it's flattering that someone
it's quaint that someone would think I
have the time to do that but I don't and
staff does also also does not delete
YouTube comments if people are seeing
YouTube comments deleted it's because
other viewers are flagging them either
as spam or attacks or whatever and I
don't even know how the YouTube
algorithm works around this but some
number of flags must get comments
removed but I have no idea what is going
on there number two
come on you have no right to leave
comments on my youtube channel it's not
an issue of free speech you have no
right to show up on my personal Twitter
page or my personal Instagram account
and leave anti-semitic insults and
whatever else if I want to block you if
I want to mute you and I admit I have
thousands of people muted on Twitter
because it is just an echo chamber
cesspool it is not an issue of free
speech and you should really rethink
that entire thing remember that the best
way to fight hate reott ism in your
local community is to get a membership
at join pakman.com and use the coupon
code hey tree at 40 the coupon code code
hey tree at 40 accomplishes two just
beautiful things one it supports the
david pakman show and two it's sort of
like a middle finger to the hey tree
it's that you will not be intimidated by
their hate reott ISM that's hey tree at
forty h80 our i/o t40 saves you 40% and
a thousand hey tree it's cry every time
the coupon code is used